كشفت دراسه نشرت هذا الاسبوع امكانيه
استخدام النمل في الكشف عن الاورام
السرطانيه بسرعه
وبتكلفه زهيده
شم دقيقه لدرجه ان الباحثين يدربونه الان
على اكتشاف رائحه الخلايا السرطانيه لدى
البشر الدراسه التي نشرت في مجله بروسيدنج
الضوء على احساس النمل الشديد وتؤكد كيف
يمكن يوما مع استخدام الحيوانات ذات الانف
الحاد لاكتشاف الاورام بسرعه
قليله
امرا مهما للغير انه كل ما تم اكتشافه
السرطان بشكل اسرع كانت فرص الشفائي افضل
نتائج واحده للغايه لكنهم من المهم ان
نعرف انا بعيدون عن استخدامها كطريقه
يوميه للكشف عن السرطان
لما استاذ المتخصصه في البيولوجيه
الجزئيه
والعلوم السرطانيه نرحب بك صيد صاله
دكتوره اصاله اذا كان الامر لن يستخدم في
الحالات اليوميه يعني الكشف اليومي عن همم
مرضى السرطان عن طريق استخدام سواء النمله
او الكلاب او كل الحيوانات
والمخلوقات ذات القدره العاليه على الشمس
فما الذي سيحققه ذلك في المستقبل
مساء الخير
طبعا لن يستخدم في الوقت الحالي يعني
الهدف من هو الذي يستخدم بشكل يومي
التاكيد على اننا في صدد اعلان نتائج
لدراسه اوليه يعني كالعاده اصبحنا نعرف
انه عندما نسمع بدرس الجديده يجب ان اتوقع
اننا بحاجه الى تعميق هذه الدراسات والى
دراستها بشكل اعماق الدراسه مهمه جدا صحيح
انه تم هناك دراسات سابقه شبيهه على
الكلاب ربما تتذكرون ايضا دراسه فرنسيسيه
همم اظهرت قدره الكلاب على الكشف عن
كورونا في البدايات
موجه الوباء همم انما المميز مع ان نعمل
هي انه لدينا قدره على تدريب هذه
المخلوقات بشكل اسرع يعني اما هو مهم جدا
بهذه الدراسه انهم اظهروا ان النمل كن
قادرا على ان يتدرب على معرفه هذه الرائحه
التي
خاصه بالفئران المريضه خلال ثلاثه ايام
فقط
اه لدي فضول كبير لكي اعرف الى انا كنت
باعت موضوع دراسه الكلاب وقدرتها على
تحديد همم الخلايا السرطانيه وكان هذا في
الواقع بحث يعني استغرق سنوات وكنا نتوقع
ان نرى نتائجه يعني في وقت ما خلال هذه
السنوات ولكن لم يحصل شيء من هذا والان
فجاه يدخل على الخط كائن جديد مخلوق صغير
جدا هو النمل يعني تدريب النمل كيف يتم
تدريب النمل ممكن ان افهم ان يدرب كلب
مثلا همم لكي يعرف او يدلنا كيف يميز ولكن
النمل كيف يدرب النمل
النمل والنحل وكل هذه الحيوانات التي تعيش
في مجتمعات هي حيوانات سهله التدريب لانه
لديها ذكاء يمكن ان يسميه ذكاء كيميائي
يعني طبعا هي لا تدرب كمان مدرب الكلاب هي
نوع مختلفه من الحيوانات النمل لديه حاسه
شمعه جدا بعض الانواع من انما العمياء
تماما هي تتبع فقط الفيرمون يعني خطوط
الروائح لتجد الاكل
للقبض على الفرائس لحمايه صغارها هي تعيش
عبر الرائحه وحتى همم يعني تشكيل المجتمع
بين ان نعمل كيف يعملون الملكه والعاملات
وكل هذا لنا مرتبط ايضا بالروائح ما حصل
لاشرح لكم التجربه بشكل مختصر جدا هم
قاموا بزرع خلايا السرطانيه في الفئران
همم نمت هذه الخلايا وشكلت سرطانات ثدي
لدى الفئران اصبح لديهم مريضه وفئران
صحيحه قاموا باخذ باول هذه الفئران همم
كيميائيا اثبت وانا باقول الفئران المريضه
لسبب ما وجود همم يعني مركبات محدده في في
فضلات هذه الفئران لديه رائحه معينه ثم
قاموا باخذ 39 نمله من نوع محدد
وعرضوا هذه ان املاك لائحه
الفئران المريضه وفي كل مره اشمت هذه
النمله الرائحه همم هذه حصلت على السكر
يعني على الطعام وخلال ثلاثه ايام تم طبعا
اعاده التجربه لعدد معين همم ربط النمل في
النهايه بين الرائحه والمكافاه الطعام
ولذا في كل مره ستكون النمله هذه الرائحه
سوف نذهب اليها لانها نمله مدربه وهذه
الرائحه نقطه بالنسبه لها بالسكر يعني
بانها سوف تحصل على طاعه عنها يعني ان
نعمل كان يذهب فقط للاجابه الطعام في
نهايه التجربه انطر النمل 30% اكثر من
وقتها عند الفئران المريضه همم وليس عن
الصحيح يعني التجربه اظهرت نتائج جيده
هكذا
معين مدرب وليس عموما النمل لانه حتى صاحب
هذه الدراسه يقول ان احد اصدقائه شعر
بالفزع حينما هجم عليه النمل في نزهه في
احدى الحدائق لكن هذا نمل معين مدرب يدربه
صاحب هذه الدراسه في شقته في الواقع
او في المختبر طبعا
في الاس
اس تغيرت في ظروف محدده جدا همم لعزل كل
المؤثرات الاخرى يعني لا يكون هناك روائح
اخرى ايضا ولا ايضا اذا قام النمل
بالاقتراب من من طعامكم هو فقط يريد السكر
هو ليس انا من المدرب طبعا هذا يعني اصابه
شخص في السرطان
شكرا جزيلا لك يا دكتوره اصاله لما ان
متخصصه في البيولوجيا الجزيئيه والعلوم
السرطانيه شكرا جزيلا ونؤمل فعلا ان تحقق
هذه الدراسه الهدف منها يعني